Paul Scheer you're welcome man how are
you
good very good sorry it's telling this
is my cannon hey my very nice movie too
I was telling Mike that people like you
Mike people I saw on Twitter logs that
write very excited that you're here yeah
you know what I'm into Mike alright make
you feel like I'm also gonna be on the
show like you could say something nice
about me no I mean he was already there
like I feel like you know I was watching
you know I gotta watch you guys see
what's going on yeah so like I was
telling Mike that I try not to speak in
hyperbole yes
but at first I was gonna say the
disaster artist is easily my most
anticipated film of the year but when I
started to like really think about it
yeah I was like I may be more excited
about this film's release than any other
film in the history of filmmaking Wow
yeah yeah yeah modern history I mean
like wow any filmmaking ever do you feel
like I by the way I believe it and I
think it's justified yeah I do I mean
for me it would be Roger Rabbit too but
you know it's definitely up there no
it's it's a crazy thing I mean if you're
a fan of the room which if you don't
know what the room is the room is this
movie made by Tommy was oh and I always
describe it as like Tennessee Williams
put through Google Translate yeah you
know it's like what am i watching this
is insane
people like don't do anything that
normal people do it's like an alien like
sauce snapshot of human behavior like I
got it yeah don't you want to do some
more research no I got it I got it like
and and you know like the characters in
this movie they drink like I think
called a scotch qey which is scotch and
vodka that no one does that that's not a
thing I've never heard of that ever
happen exactly so it's like one of the
most insane things in it this movie is
so bizarre and so weird
it's got this like big cult following
but then as years have come out like you
started to understand the guy behind the
movie this guy Tommy was oh yeah he's
one of the most interesting bizarre
dudes a dude that you could literally
ask what did you eat for breakfast and
he will not give you a straight answer
know that like he is
not of again not of this world like he
like yeah it's amazing with this with
this movie because like you watch it and
in your head I think the first time
people watch it though as long as some
people are just like this sucks but
right the people get obsessed with it
yeah they start trying to think of ideas
of like how did this happen what was his
thinking here and then the guy who stars
in it Greg Sestero wrote this book
called the disaster artist and you read
this book and the actual story behind
the making of this movie is so far
beyond whatever you could come up with
in your own head it's amazing it yeah
it's like I always say if you don't like
the room you're wrong you know what it
what it is is like it the room is like
an ayahuasca experience right because
you like you like you hear about it I
want to do that that was even the fun
you got to get the right group of people
to walk you through it and but then
you're there's gonna be moments Rick I
got to leave this is terrible and those
friends have to be like no no no it gets
better you have to sit through yeah if
you've walked out of the room or if not
watch the full thing I urge you stick
with it because it does pay off it's the
only move that gets better and better
and then when you hear the stories
behind the movie yes it's it's
fascinating and like so I thought I'd
done it all right I saw the movie
multiple times I read the book and then
I listened to the book on tape because
Greg Cisneros Tommy was so impression
it's like the most incredible thing
you've ever heard then III did it all
right right I go to one of these
screenings where Greg is there you know
doing he reads from the original script
and like I gotten to know him a little
bit right through my obsession and he
goes have you ever seen the script for
the movie and I was like no I hadn't
even thought of it and he goes Sam
the original script for the room is so
much weirder than the actual movie he's
like here and he gives me the script and
I'm like what the [ __ ] is this I just
saw that Tommy amazing marketer sells
the script on his website for $17.99
this guy has made the biggest movie like
I guess the best worst movie ever but
he's marketed it to such an extreme like
yeah he makes Kevin Hart look like like
you like he is like a slacking yeah and
you know it's like Tommy's got his own
underwear he's got his own insurance
the ideas he's like okay I got DVDs
I got movie posters I guess I should do
underwear odd things like when you
buying his DVD off his website you get a
cart in there it's a get some time it
was all underwear and I'm gonna tell you
they're pretty comfortable but it's also
you get the DVD off the website because
you have to yeah because it's nowhere
digitally yes oh god it's not on iTunes
or Netflix right you can't buy it
anywhere except on his web so it is like
read I had to buy read oh yes my
favorite movie last night oh my gosh
I had to buy that off of some weirdos
website right well the only difference
is that that's probably not like like
they thought like the guy who made rad
going like I'm not I don't want to share
this with the world
Tommy's like oh can I make a ton of
money he put cuz I can print a blu-ray
DVD for like 50 Cent's and selfie for
$21 yeah yeah like he's a smart
businessman right yeah so three years
ago I had Tommy in here and it was need
to listen to that it's look I have for
an hour and it did you get any did you
ever get an answer out of them do it not
only did I not get an answer but like
the questions he would look at me like I
was asking stupid questions like
something that I learned in the book
which I'm sure you get talked about in
the in the film is that and this was
groundbreaking nobody had done this
before Tommy built a contraption so that
he could use two cameras to shoot the
movie simultaneously on film as well as
1080 HD video Wow because he didn't know
which was gonna work right but the thing
about it is like when that's been double
them yet it's two different you'd like
you can't light you can't have one set
of lighting for both those things it
doesn't work you also can't shoot
anything simultaneously because every
frame will be slightly off so and that's
the way the movie is kind of presented
it these are the choices the other thing
about Tommy was you know in in in
Hollywood or whatever you rent equipment
right because of depreciation yes Tommy
bought all the equipment because of
depreciation don't you understand that
your reasoning for buying it is the
reasoning why should rent because
depreciation
she is a character like he once told me
he's like Paul just asked me whatever
you want to ask me and I said well
alright well how old are you and then he
proceeded to tell me a five-minute story
about building a steel building with his
bare hands and how he had these
beautiful windows but not a strong
foundation and then I was like right
okay how old are you and he's like you
can't have good windows without a
foundation I was like okay next question
alright dude he was in here and he said
move on next question I mean over and
over because you try to go back to him
and you go like wait wait wait but I
don't think you actually said he goes
but move on next question I will say
that one of the best things about Tommy
and I think one of the things that the
disaster artist does really well is it
doesn't set out to be like this rosetta
stone of the room it gives you like this
a picture of these two guys and it
doesn't answer those questions because I
think if you answer those questions if
if you find out how old he is
where he got his money all these things
she fashions you I say yes yes - oh my
god he sold jeans people it's like
finding out about midi-chlorians and
star wars it's like oh did that make it
better right no I did it and so I think
what's kind of fun about the disaster
artist is you can see you can really see
it without ever having to see the room
but I guarantee you if you see the
disasters you're gonna want to go see
them yeah immediately and definitely and
for you especially stay for the
post-credits sequence at the very end of
the movie there is a it's like the the
closest thing to a Marvel so yeah it's
it's so the very end of the credits you
will be pleasantly surprised but so I
bring up the cameras because he ended up
putting when he put the movie out
obviously he just used what he shot with
the film camera right and then he's in
here and he's got the blu-ray of the
room and I go so Tommy we have the
blu-ray here and he goes yes and I go
and is the blu-ray a direct film
transfer and he goes yes and I go okay
you shot the movie in HD you never used
it blu-ray is an HD format why didn't
you use the HD version of the film for
the blu-ray and he goes because film is
better move on next question yes it's
incredible
it's the only time I was telling our
producer Travis's it's the only time
that Lake I don't work in film right I
do radio you know this is the only time
that a film has ever been produced that
I'm like oh I wish I was working on that
movie they don't work in movies wow it's
amazing because you realize how much you
know about movies by seeing the room
because it takes everything that you
know and throws it out the way oh that's
not like anyone can watch the room and
God is wrong here like yeah that's like
you you you know something's up
immediately dude were you aware when you
guys are making because I think when
people first found out the disasters was
gonna be made into a movie it felt like
Franco and Rogan were just kind of doing
this passion project cuz they loved the
room and they were gonna get a bunch of
guys like you who also and like just
make a fun movie for those of us that
are obsessed and as the months go on
Oscar buzz pops up and it sounding of
everybody's top 10 list of movies of the
year and and I'm going like what how
when did this happen
well I think what it is it's like
there's two ways you could make the
movie right one is like the the
Bowfinger version where you're kind of
like punching down and it's like making
fun of it and the other way was how can
we make this dumb movie where they're
basically making a really dumb movie
like about the worst movie ever made
how can we make that really really smart
and I think what Seth and Franco did was
they got these amazing screenwriters the
guys were at like 500 days of summer
spectacular now Paper Towns
you know like like to write this like
emotional story about these two guys
Tommy and Greg and that's your entry
point for this movie you're hearing
you're watching like like this reverse
lala land you know it's like you know
these two people with big dreams that it
doesn't work out quite well for ya and
or does it works out well for them but
just not in the way that we're used to
it we rang out you know and so I think
they really said it set out to build a
foundation of a real movie and then all
put all the funny stuff on top of it so
there's something about this movie you
know I was obviously in it I was
invested in it but when you watch it
you're like I'm like emotionally moved
by certain things like you feel moved by
Tommy like James Franco adds a level of
humanity to
tell me that I've never seen from actual
Tommy uh-huh you know and I think that
that is I think that that is kind of the
the benefit of the movie it's a really
it's a movie about these two guys that
are helping each other make this piece
of art that is art in and the most sure
here yeah right you know what the room
as a movie I think it's art because you
can feel somebody's hands on it you know
yeah like you could tell a person a guy
for better or worse created this movie
it's not a corporate yes thing there's
so few films in the world that are
untouched by any one of those films like
Steven Spielberg has amazing DPS and
nobuk I'm gonna do this shot in the deep
um I will do it like this tongue is like
no I'll tell you how we're gonna do it
I wrote it I'm gonna act in it he was
doing every part of it Frank you know
Greg had stolen all these things from
Tommy and like audio tapes of Tommy like
recording things to himself his thoughts
to himself and also this document this
documentary that Tommy made about the
making of the room he had someone
following them around documentary is the
most boring thing ever it's like eight
hours and it's like I've seen like
security cam footage that is more
interesting but have certain points I
was I was scrubbing through it you could
watch Tommy on set he's like yelling at
people or you're not yelling but like
giving people notes and knowing paying
him any mind and it and it was like so
is interesting to see like but this is a
guy like he was fully in control like he
write whatever you saw there is 100% one
person's vision and I feel like that is
the success because there's like only
like four movies I think that is one
person that's such an interesting ting -
and the way you tell that story is how
you get pulling on people's heartstrings
is that like on one end you've got Tommy
kind of being a dick and ordering people
around even though he doesn't know what
he's doing but on the other end you've
got all these people that he hired
they're like treating him like an answer
well like not paying any attention to
him and then you feel like bad for him
right
well I mean look I believe this firmly I
think the reason why Tommy made the room
is because he wanted companionship
friendship you wanted love like you this
is a guy who to me
feels like he's a little bit of an
island you know and he wants to have it
so the movie went on like it was like a
65 movie that took place on sets they
didn't even go anyway over you know so
and and he I don't think he wanted the
movie then because then his friends
would go away you know and and and and
and there's something like really
wonderful about like this guy's like I
just want I want my friends around and
that was the only way he was gonna get
there are they're they're a bunch of
rooftop scenes in the movie yes where
it's like it's really poorly green
screened you know a background of a
cityscape and you don't realize until
you read the book or see the movie
obviously that the green screens were
placed outdoors they build an Ali set
inside the stages when they're shooting
next 200 hours like that is the level of
stuff that is going on so I think the
movie I think if you're a room fan it
really pays off a lot of those things
and you know doesn't have everything
from the book but it definitely gives
you an idea of some of the better you
know that the heightened parts of the
book but it really does tell the story I
think you understand Tommy a little bit
which is you know that's that's the
hardest thing what was your what was
your take away from Greg from Greg
Sestero who's the guy who is the co-star
of the original room movie but he spent
like he wrote the book yes he spent he
lived with Tommy he spent all this time
because like I've talked to him a bunch
yeah right and and the one thing that's
still I've interviewed him I've talked
to him privately like you know I text
with him yeah and I still can't wrap my
head around exactly what the
relationship was or what his motivation
was because he's so aware of like he is
right look I will tell you I think Greg
is the sweetest nicest yes and this is
my opinion on their relationship it's
like the cool kid in high school who's
friends with the nerd right it's like
that nerd he's a nerd I know but but
then wouldn't like the doors are closed
they came in we're buddies but he is
aware and he is smart but I think he
genuinely like like
and loves their friends they hang out
they do and there is like yes he knows
that he's got all these quirks but I
really believe that there is like a love
there you know it there you are
for better for worse their success is
tied together right and and they protect
each other and their and they treat each
other well and I feel like it but that's
like that's and whenever I see them I'm
like you're the cool kid who has a nerdy
friend it doesn't want to admit that you
really like that nerdy friend my bet
Tommy sees himself as the cool kid right
a friend named grow cuz he told me that
the book yeah he's maybe fifty fifty oh
but maybe fifty fifty but the movie is
ninety-nine point nine oh wow yes the
movie and he goes and go and so what's
the like the one like that one percent
of a percent and he goes that goes there
the way he threw the football
I have throw a football better the only
the only error in the entire morning but
you know it's they think you know I
think that uh yeah it's an interesting
relationship if if Tommy and Greg didn't
talk I don't think that this story would
be as interesting but they are still in
it they just made a movie together they
travel around the world together and
they are they are like he is the Tommy
whisperer
you know Greg is the only one who I
think really understands Tommy yeah it's
it's a complicated relationship it's
like family or some my favorite part of
the book is when Greg I'm sure you've
read the book oh yeah any time I've read
the book but I've even if I recommend to
anybody listen to it on audio okay
that's a pass because he is amazing at
doing it yeah yeah but yeah my favorite
part of the book is when Greg is
describing a living with Tommy and I
think it's like his first night in LA
there and he sleeps on the floor and
Tommy goes good night Greg and then he
goes into the shower and starts singing
a whole new world
well Greg is trying to sleep on the
floor he it's it's it's yeah it's like
Tommy is this its money when you watch
the movie and you don't if you don't
know Tommy
I think you're going Oh James Franco is
doing like a Borat
my character and then when you finally
see Tommy you're like oh hey that's real
had you met Tommy before you did the
movie I did or I haven't met him but I
had been at screenings that he had been
at shaking you and I knew Greg yes so
but yeah I so yeah that's how I knew him
and so I knew I knew that that is what
existed but it was so funny when I was
on set you know James Franco's in all
this makeup and but it was really good
booking makeup and I was really was
thinking the entire time was like Franco
like he's like looking guy like he's
fine yeah yeah yeah but everything but
because I was like he's wearing his
naked like everyone says like so
attractive is like whatever but like oh
I just got so used him when he finally
took off the makeup look oh yeah you're
gorgeous so used to seeing James's Tommy
Tommy for like a month that I was like I
was just like accepted my because I
didn't know James really before the
movie besides seeing when movies is
tough so my accepting my hate my
experience of James Franco was talking
with him and only it's Tommy which is
only yeah it's so funny because they'd
like Netflix did you see the Jim Carrey
thing they talked about fascinated
amazing right i watch it two nights
back-to-back because i was blown away by
what was going on so what you're
watching that are you like I see the
similarities in the in the Tommy Wiseau
James Franco think the difference is Jim
Carrey pissed everybody off yeah James
Franco wasn't like method it wasn't like
I am Tommy you cannot talk to me I'm
like he was just affecting like you
could talk to James Franco about
anything he would just talk to you as
like it was almost like Tommy's voice
and mannerisms just came through the cuz
he's like oh this is silly haha he was
commenting it as James it was with it's
a weirder thing I think he's the first
director to ever
the first method director you know yeah
Weezy I knew he could have been that
method because otherwise he'd have to do
kind of a shitty job directly master art
yeah can't do no yeah like it wasn't
like you couldn't talk to James it was
like but you were just hearing James s
Tommy right which he's a very hard thing
to wrap your head around and
and I think fascinating too because you
all you want to do is talk to James
because it's like I'm getting it's not
to taught me so how did you get involved
in the movie did you have to audition or
did your reputation precedes you
everything you know no you know it was
really I've been really lucky to kind of
work a lot with Seth Rogen and Evan
Goldberg and they brought me him for the
first table read and the table read
James is already full Tommy and the fan
of the room I was like oh my god this is
amazing
I had great to stero on my podcast how
did this get made before he wrote the
book uh-huh so I had heard some of those
stories so I was really fascinated when
I heard they were making this movie so I
got there and I assume like James was
like oh I know he does his podcast and
that's why he probably brought you know
why you brought me in there and then I
just found that like a couple weeks ago
I didn't even know you did that on those
like you know I just got brought in to
do the table read and then we were all
giving notes on the script which was
already in a great spot when we did it
and I think just James and like like the
fact that I knew a lot about the room
and it come do the movie and and the
movie is really cool because it is
populated with so many people that you
know oh yeah you know it's like every
every role is filled by someone in a
cool way whether it's you know Megan
Mullally or Bryan Cranston or Jason
Mantzoukas Gina ray feel like you know
it's like is Zac Efron Josh Hutcherson
it's like everywhere you look Nathan
fielder it's like there is someone in
there like oh my god it's so yeah it's a
really it's fun to watch that way yeah
it's so cool I'd say I mean it's just so
cool the things getting made and it's
getting as much mainstream attention oh
it's it's and I think to the credit of
everybody involved they made a good
movie and I think like and it does
service like for Tommy go 99.9 percent
and this book is only fifty it's like
should you is there any part of you that
starts to feel like because you are on
this thing so early yeah that feels like
you're your that's my band that's
becoming famous no I am excited because
it's like I want people to experience
the room yeah there you know rocky our
picture show very campy it's ivory one
knows the Rocky Horror Picture Show if
you even if you saw if you didn't I
don't think people know the room I think
it's a smaller group of people that are
familiar with this film and I hope that
this movie will bring attention to both
of these things and you watch them
almost as a double feature but I want
more people to be watching the room
and learn about cuz it's still one of
those things we go oh yeah we're doing a
movie about the making of the room like
the room the room like oh I never heard
of it because it is still a little it's
a little underground it is I'm excited
for it too you know it's more like I'm
excited big I listen to this band and
now they got a major record deal you
know right hopefully Tom had or upgrade
his broadband for his website by the way
check out that website if you get a
change in my room comm it's I think it's
the room movie don't come yes that makes
perfect sense the room movie like when
you look at this it is like submit was
created in the late 80s scroll down just
a little bit really a Geo site yeah like
it's I mean you're looking at it's like
there's like weird flag emojis nothing
is this looks like a flat earth website
yeah yeah it is it is amazing they had
the the room movie.com oh my gosh but
yeah he is he is organic he is authentic
I know a lot people go like well but he
knows he's in on the joke I think he's
in on a joke but it's not the joke to
worry enough no he thinks that like he's
now in control of the joke yes but it's
not the same job look they were and then
you'll do things that are so funny he's
like I was at dinner with him one time
and he just started laughing like what
are you laughing at Tommy because I'm
just you don't want to know just
thinking of being naked on a beach just
thinking of himself naked on a beach
like that's the that's Tommy like I like
when I have people on the show that are
kind of off-center yeah I like to have
my interaction with them on the air and
then yeah yeah kind of yeah around after
so when he came in here I had him come
in while we were on the air and I had
two friends in that had never seen the
room before it was just like and so as
soon as we're over and take picture
thanks man that was so great and I go to
the bathroom right figuring he'll be
gone by the time I get back I get back
and he's still holding court in here of
course he's not gonna leave no and so I
walk in and like just when you
think some of it might be an act he goes
oh thank you Sam I go oh yeah man thanks
for coming he goes do you want me to
bless you what and I was like looks like
yeah I guess and he did and he goes okay
about your head
and so I bowed my head he takes out a
tommy wiseau dog tag he kisses it he
puts it around my neck and puts it on
and then he crosses himself and he goes
you are blessed amazing you can't get
better than that holy crap like he does
those dog tags this guy is it I can tell
you he's a master marketer like his
website and everything you can buy isn't
it's it all goes directly to tell me all
proceeds to tell me I thought in an
effort to familiarize as much as we've
been talking about him I actually have
the the liners oh yeah would you want to
hear the liners 100% and Mike you'd want
to I'm very excited you're going to hear
these two yes so keep in mind like my
name's Sam Roberts right he's got a
tough name it's a pretty pretty
straightforward 100% broadcaster name
some people think it's fake it's not
fake yeah and I just talk to him for an
hour right so it's like what you've
talked and we're familiar by the way if
you're not here we're in a studio in
which all every Mike says Sam Robin so
we had Troy bring him into the other
studio where they do production and I
think we have what we got from him do we
have a Travis yes
hey this is Tommy was oh and you we are
back more with Sam other show hey we are
back from hey we are back okay hey we
are back more with Sam Roberts show we
are back more from we are back more of
samurais show let me do on the same
rabbit show yeah okay we are back more
of Sam Roberts show hey this is Tommy
Wiseau and you listen Sam a rubbish show
we are back we are back more of Sam
Roberts Joe hey hey you listen Sam
Roberts show I just made he made Troy's
job easier because he added those for
your show yeah but the fact of the
matter is there was these large spaces
of dead air where he's just literally
standing in front of the microphone not
doing anything I'm like what the hell is
going on here right I know go you're
listening to Sam Robb having a PTSD
moment is like recording promise oh I
did a movie with it so I'm in like Tommy
and Greg say that they have completed
the trilogy which is the room the
disaster artist and then they've made
another film together called best
friends they have yes it's a two-part
film I was not aware of that when I got
the script oh it was one script and greg
has said will you come and do a part in
the movie I said absolutely they do it
like Kill Bill like they did a napping
Whoopi and they're gonna split it into
two there was the script pages did not
dictate that it would be a two-parter
from what I saw but 11 page so yeah
there's not an organic spot in the
script where you're like oh obviously
this is a second so she goes will you
come and do a part I said absolutely and
so I do my part with Tommy in a morgue
which is amazing gut getting to equity
me who again he's traveled the world
he's doing these promos you're
interviewing him he's going around
although he is not unfamiliar with doing
stuff
It was as if he was on set for the first
like okay like we're doing these scenes
and then we were like let's open it up
we'll improvise a little bit and my
character's name in that movie is Malmo
and he goes no mo mo no mo mo his
improvising was just saying no
I know Momo and it was never doing
anything besides is a no mama and so I
shot it that's the old improv rule of
you know ya know I just repeat the
character's name yeah so I you know shot
it and it was fun there's a part of me
that thought I was being pranked you
know there's like a million people
around documenting the thing and so
about a year passes and I get like I see
a tweet and it was like hey I loved you
in best friends Greg just screened it in
Scandinavia whenever it was and he says
you're gonna be in part two I was like
part two who it makes equal and and yeah
and it's like I don't know how they cut
up the iid like there's not enough there
shouldn't be enough footage for two no
no I'm in two parts of it but I will say
that I was there on the day where they
they had this final scene where a guy in
a motorcycle rides into a driveway right
and this big imposing guy so I percent
out a thing on Craigslist or whatever to
get somebody to ride a motorcycle one so
mister no I can do it and they've this
big I don't know anything about
motorcycles but I know it's like a big
giant like Harley like one of those ones
that you look at you're like whoa this
is it's a monster you know and the guy
gets there and he's like oh I've never
rode that kind of motorcycle and there
what do you mean he's like I'm only a
dirt bike rider and they're yeah you
could do it no he could got on that
thing and it was like a scooby-doo
cartoon he hit the gas the motorcycle
like shot out from like underneath this
guy like he fell on the ground I'm like
oh my god like I'm gonna be on the death
I couldn't look there's gonna be a death
on this movie and you know that and
they're like well we got to make this
scene work we got to make it
intimidating so the way that they kind
of like figured it out was they they
don't think that the guy walked the
motorcycle into the driveway like oh the
the bad guys back bike stalled